good news josh mcdaniels is still there
better news NICUs REO is staying
however with tom brady's free agency
coming this has the potential to be a
very crazy and hectic offseason for the
Patriots Dante's Garnett Kia the
offensive line coach is retired which is
not good for the offense generally so
all things considered this is the most
important offseason for viewing the
Patriots franchise since fill in the
blank I'm gonna say I'm gonna say 2010
because everybody thinks the Patriots
win Super Bowls year after year after
year and while it seems like that they
did have this nine year stretch when
they had no Super Bowl victories yes
they went but they didn't win one in
that stretch so in 2008 if you remember
Tom Brady tears his ACL in the first
game they have a winning record they
don't go to the postseason next season
they lose in the wild-card round which
was the last time they lost in the wild
called wildcard round until this year
then they lose then Pease and they have
all these things going on and they had a
great draft that year that's when they
got Rob Gronkowski that's when they got
some of those guys Devin McCourty who
are so important to where they are now
so I think that was kind of the
offseason that started propelling them
back into a Super Bowl team now I didn't
you know took a couple more years for
they won one but then they got rolling
and now we see them as annual
participants in the Super Bowl and
contenders for the Super Bowl and I
think that's a great choice because they
got blown off the field at home in the
wild-card round by the Baltimore Ravens
that year and this is the first time
since then that they made an exit that
early from the postseason but I think
it's I'm gonna go all the way back to
2000 when they picked up Bill Belichick
in trade in January and found a guy
named Tom Brady and round six of the
draft a couple of months later and
nobody really knew where the Patriots
were gonna go and what they were gonna
be in 2000 2000 want to be on but this
just feels like the most significant and
potentially tumultuous offseason for the
Patriots since then and it's critical
that they make good decisions we talked
earlier about how important it will be
for teams to know who their quarterback
is going to be quickly before the
options get gobbled up the Patriots need
to know what Brady is going to do they
need to know if he's going to
bark on a free agency tour and visit a
bunch of different teams and if he's
gonna do that they can't sit around and
wait for him to maybe decide the grass
isn't greener anywhere else they gotta
have somebody ready to go and it
wouldn't shock me if they actually had
someone lined up to come in and then
Brady decides he wants to stay after all
and the Patriots have to figure out how
to wade their way out of that mess but
they can't afford to wait they're gonna
have to get this figured out they have
to have a quarterback they like and
maybe they love Jared stille him enough
to do it and just make him the guy and
then they can wait for Tom Brady to go
out and check out five six seven eight
different teams but I think they're
gonna need to move quickly it's gonna be
critical and I think this is the most
important offseason for them since the
year the Belichick and Brady arrived all
right Patrick well Holmes and Russell
Wilson are MGM's favorites Coe favorites
for MVP next year if you had to pick one
non quarterback favorite to win the MVP
award for the 2020 season it would be
blank well you know the name that pops
out immediately is Michael Thomas just
because of what he did in setting the
NFL record one offensive player of the
year but a receivers never won the award
not even Jerry Rice so how do you pick a
receiver in this scenario and and I
can't I would be more apt to pick Aaron
Donald than I would be to pick Michael
Thomas chip just for that simple fact
but I'm gonna go with who I think now
has become based on what he did in the
postseason the best running back in the
NFL and that's Derek Henry that's a team
depending on what they do at quarterback
that could go to the Super Bowl next
season and I think you're gonna see them
as contenders they've just gotten better
and better under Mike Vrabel and Derek
Henry is gonna lead the way for that
team no doubt about doesn't matter who
they get at quarterback Derek Henry's
gonna lead the way and I think he's
probably gonna lead the league in
rushing again unless he gets hurt yeah
and I agree with you and if Derek Henry
can get off to a fast start something
that he's never done in in his NFL
career he could get 2000 yards or more
this guy's gotten better and better and
better each year of his career he
reminds me of Jim Brown and when he gets
moving he needs a few steps to get
moving but once he gets moving he is
unstoppable I'm gonna go back to Thomas
though here's why Thomas has a chance
every year that there's been a great
performance by a receiver
and who has been potentially MVP worthy
his quarterback ends up being the MVP
that's how it goes this year I think
Drew Brees is gonna stay and I think
we're going to see a sharing of that job
between Drew Brees and Taysom Hill the
handwriting is already on the wall that
that's what's coming so you could have
Michael Thomas having gigantic numbers
you could have neither quarterback
having the kind of numbers that cry out
MVP and then that would give Michael
Thomas the opening I just can't imagine
him having another season like he did
last year when he set the all-time
record for one NFL campaign with 149
catches and I thought he would get a
little more steam for MVP last year with
Lamar Jackson I don't think anybody else
was getting any steam for it but that
was the year drew Brees missed five
games and that's a year or receiver if
ever is going to stand out all right
shot Conn the owner of the Jaguars said
his team has an embarrassment of riches
at quarterback not to be confused with
the times that the quarterback situation
in Jacksonville was just flat-out
embarrassing blank is the team with the
actual best quarterback situation in the
league Shareen well you know it's
obviously this past season was the
Saints with what they had but since all
three of those guys are now free agents
she can't go with the Saints I'm gonna
go with San Francisco 49ers I know there
are a lot of questions after the Super
Bowl about Jimmy G but it's probably
more for my love for Nick Mullens and
and what he did last year when in 2018
when when Jimmy G was out I think this
is a really good quarterback I used to
be a great quarterback in league and
whether it's for the 49ers or somebody
else they trade him somewhere else this
is gonna be a good quarterback in this
league I think based on what he did in
that small sample size
when Jimmy G was out and then they have
CJ Beathard so I think they have a great
quarterback situation in San Francisco
assuming Jimmy G can can be the guy they
think he can be yeah but he had a chance
to be the guy they think he can be and
he missed Emmanuel Sanders open and I'm
not forgetting that anytime soon even
though some 49ers fans would prefer that
I do actually they should prefer that he
made the throw then there would be
nothing for us to talk about when it
comes to limitations on Jimmy G I'm
gonna stick with the Saints though
because I think Brees will be back and
he'll I think they're gonna match
whatever
offer is coming their way there are
people who think that Sean Payton has
been talking about Taysom Hill getting
an offer sheet from a team at the bottom
of Round one because Payton would rather
have the first round pick I think that
he wants someone to do his negotiating
for him that that when you sign the
offer sheet all right all you have to do
if you're the sane to say well match it
good and I think they're gonna match
whatever offer shitty signs I think it's
gonna be Hill I think it's gonna be
Brees I doubt they're gonna be able to
keep teddy bridgewater but I could see
something like maybe a chase Daniel
working his way back to New Orleans he
was there at one point a veteran
quarterback who sees an opportunity to
hey if Drew Brees gets injured come in
and play a good bit and and play with an
offensive mastermind like Sean Payton so
they'll find another teddy bridgewater
to go with Payton and he'll and I think
they'll be in great shape for 2020 all
right the Buccaneers appeared to tease
new uniforms on Twitter yesterday
Buccaneers aside the blank need new
jerseys more than anyone else
well the Browns are getting new jerseys
and I don't know how much you can do
with the colors that they have in the
plain helmet but they need to go back to
something more traditional that is just
an awful uniform of course I'm not a big
fan of orange anyway as we all know my
love for the Aggies you can't like
aren't orange so I'm not a big fan of
the orange but the colors are just dull
but they messed up those uniforms when
they change them what was that five
years ago and they need to go back to I
think to something at least more
traditional that looks a little bit
better not much you can do with the
helmet but at least the gray facemask I
like that better than white facemask and
I know they still have the gray but
they've got to do something to improve
those uniforms this year I knew this was
gonna happen when Nike became the
official apparel provider of the NFL
back in 2012 and it's actually good that
the NFL requires players to use only one
helmet all year or we would see Nike
getting these teams to be like Oregon
used to be where you have a different
helmet every week they want to change
uniforms all the time and one thing I've
noticed recently I'm gonna get on my
soapbox here for a minute it's not we
didn't do airing of grievances this week
so I'm gonna head there a grievance I
don't like it when teams make these
uniform changes
without giving the fans at least one
years notice that that Jersey you're
buying is about to be rendered obsolete
so maybe you should wait a year and you
know like if you if you're buying your
kid a Christmas present and it's the
Matt Ryan Jersey and the Falcons
announced right after the season ends
hey we're getting new uniforms this year
kind of like to have known that in
advance since the Buccaneers are going
to be changing their uniforms now if
they like the Falcons have been secretly
we reworking their uniforms I would have
liked to have known that before I bought
that Jameis well Jameis Winston may not
be there anyway but before I bought that
Bucs Jersey if somebody was actually
gonna be there I'd like to have known
that if I waited a few months I'd have
had the new one all that said the jersey
that needs to go is the Seahawks
alternate Jersey that's screaming retina
burning highlighter yellow whatever that
is that lime yellow crap that they wear
that has got to go
and when they pair it with the pants I
bet it makes me long for the days
Shireen of black and white TV because
that's as bad as it gets
fortunately I don't wear that all the
time all right Jim Zorn was shocked by
the amount of access that the XFL gives
to fans if ya if you didn't see it you
can hear the coach calling plays you
hear the quarterback communications
they're in the locker room at halftime
blank is the best idea that the XFL has
created well I think you probably agree
with this one it definitely was the
kickoff and yeah I think you said it it
was those electric football games that
you and I grew up with playing and
that's exactly what it looked like with
the two teams lined up five yards apart
and waiting till the returner caught the
ball to return it and more than 90% of
the kickoffs were returned you cut out
the injury factor and that's what we
want to see we want to see a kickoff but
we don't want to see all those injuries
and I think they found a way to do that
and I think this is something that the
NFL needs to look at needs to look at
pretty quickly to make it work because
it's fantastic I think we all enjoyed
that that part of the XFL game and I
hope that pride doesn't keep the NFL
from adopting this if that's the right
thing it's not like it's patented by the
XFL if the NFL
wants to do it they can do it but
there's always been that resistance to
do something that someone else does but
wouldn't it be something if the XFL
right out of the gates has found the
solution that the NFL has been searching
for in vain for the last decade it
reduces it eliminates the high speed
impact that can cause catastrophic
injury it looks great I mean it really
does it's I I was I was I was having to
fit into stalled over electric football
then I remembered how frustrating the
damn game is and there's nostalgia went
away quickly but but that yeah seeing
those guys standing there you know
frozen in motion like the and that's
what they need to do they need to start
adopting the poses of the the various
electric football players while they're
waiting for the returner to catch the
ball but I think it's great that's by
far the best thing they've done and I
hope the NFL is paying attention and is
willing to do what is needed to improve
its kickoff and make it safer
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports